this is a production of cornell
university
all right hi everybody my name is
savannah shellnutt i'm a second year
master's student in larry smartz program
and really my work over the past
on evaluating different hemp production
systems for new york state so
first year i looked at high density
plantings direct seed and high density
plantings last year i was involved with
a project sponsored by the new york farm
viability institute and we were
evaluating uh
the economic production differences
between high tunnels the outdoors and
greenhouses and during that trial we
noticed that there was an elevated
incidence of powdery mildew in our
tunnels and in order to make
high tunnels a really easily manageable
system in new york state we decided to
come up with a little fungicide
trial to determine what works best for
us so my advisor larry
knows somebody from utah state and he
stated that they thought that applying
velocinite which is a silicon crystal to
the soil might enable us to easily
control powdery mildew in our tunnels
and the idea with that is that you apply
the silicon one time or twice a year
and you just leave it in the soil the
plant uptakes it into the leaf and you
don't have to worry beyond that
so we decided to
use a soil applied silicon treatment we
also have a foliar treatment which is
still matrix and then we wanted to use
popular biological uh control so we went
with mill stop and cease and then we
also have trigo which is a conventional
um fungicide
so uh the reason we chose this layout
for this trial um is we were initially
thinking that we would apply
the uh velocinite or the vancil twice in
the season but uh after some further
evaluation we decided we just wanted to
do it early season so that's why the
soil is exposed in the plots uh because
we wanted easy access to mix in the loss
tonight throughout the season
additionally there's wide spacing
between the plants because i come
through here once a week and i rate each
plant for its powdery mildew incidence
so if the leaves are touching each other
or the plants all crossed up it's
difficult to rate for powdery mildews
that's why we chose this four foot
spacing between plants and
we opted with white landscape fabric
just to try to keep the heat down in
here i don't know if you've noticed but
it's much hotter in here than it is
outside it's about
90 degrees in here and it's in the mid
70s outside and also i have this exact
trial replicated in the grow dome and
the grow dome it's probably about 95
degrees right now so it's very warm in
there so powdery mildew as ali and chris
were talking about earlier it is a
fungal pathogen
of a hemp
and basically how powdery mildew works
is that the canadian land on a leaf
and it uh generates a hersudia which is
basically a little root-like structure
that penetrates down into the leaf and
acts as sort of you can think of it
rudimentarily as like a straw and it
sucks the nutrients it needs up into the
host so
and so the idea behind applying silicon
to the uh
to the plants is that silicon is an
important constituent of plant cell
walls it helps to strengthen the cell
wall and so if there is a high level of
silicon in the plant cell in theory you
would think it would be more difficult
for the
powder milder to penetrate into the
plant
so these plants we started them in the
greenhouse
uh middle of may they were allowed to
grow for four weeks we transplanted them
out allowed them to grow for five weeks
vegetatively
and then we came in and inoculated and
sprayed all of our treatments for the
first time the day before we inoculated
we inoculated about four months uh four
weeks ago and we've been rating and
spraying weekly since then
um if you are curious about the rates
that we're using you can use the qr code
outside to pull up our
our
our sheet here yep and so um yeah so
just a little
information on how the different
products work uh mil stop and see
mill stop is
a sodium bicarbonate and that works by
altering the ph of the leaf so fungus
really likes
low ph environments so it looks more
acidic environment and sodium
bicarbonate is basically baking soda it
elevates the ph of the leaf surface and
makes it difficult for the powdery
mildew to grow and that's mixed with a
strain of bacillus which is cease cease
forms a biofilm on the leaf surface it
makes it difficult for the powdered
mildew to establish itself because it
has to compete with another living thing
on the surface of the leaf
and then we have trigo that's a
more conventional
option there it's actually only labeled
for ornamentals so since we're not using
these plants
we're just looking at them it's okay to
use and we chose that because we wanted
to prove that we could effectively
control powdery mildew in the tunnel and
that works by inhibiting the respiratory
pathway of the fungus so that means that
it's more difficult for the fungus to
create energy when it's on leaf surface
so so far we are three weeks into this
project and as you can see we have
plenty of powdery mildew germinating on
our leaves we chose the cultivar white
cbg because it's known to be highly
susceptible to powdery mildew and i
invite you all to walk around and look
and ask questions you'll you'll notice
that there are some differences between
the different treatments this treatment
this so each
row of plants is a replicate
and so this row right here is labeled
very simply so you can see what it is
but if you want to walk around and look
at other plots if you look on that end
of the plots there's a yellow tag yep
did you start on the same time
yes yeah
so yeah i don't know i invite you all to
look at the high tunnel or at the grow
dome the pla some of the plants in there
over eight feet tall so
just check it out um but um
yeah so just feel free to walk around
look at the plants ask me any questions
you might have you can go ahead and you
can notice some differences between the
different treatments there's nothing
concrete right now but i mean obviously
the trifloxi strobe and triangle is
working great everything else there is a
little bit of powder and it'll do here
and there so
a couple of people have asked me two
questions one did you start these from
seed or cuttings before bringing them
out and the other
uh why do you think the plants are such
different heights okay that's a great
question so question is did i start the
plants from seeds or cuttings so this is
all started from seed and as you know
when you start from seed it's a mixed
bag
you are
you hope that your plants are stable but
sometimes they're segregating for
different treats so another question is
why are my plants different heights so
if you stand out back here and look
you'll notice that those plants are
pretty stunted these plants are fairly
stunted these are okay size that is
because a week after we planted uh the
signs of the we hadn't had the science
program correctly at the time and it
just dumped rain and flooded those
outside plots and it took about two
weeks for them to dry out
um so yeah that is from water
flooding stunting um
right there and then within the plots
you might notice some variable height
this population of plants is segregating
for flowering time so uh some of the
plants started flowering about three
weeks ago and some of them just started
flowering this week and a few of them
you'll notice haven't really quite
gotten there yet um so obviously when
the plant begins to grow
uh starts to flower it ceases its um
vegetative growth so that's some of the
variable height within the plots
um any other questions welcome
yes
yeah so the question is uh is there any
anticipated post harvest issues quality
issues with the silica and so we have
taken uh leaf samples from all of our
silica plots and the control plot we're
going to compare what the level of
silica is in the control and in the leaf
of the foliar applied silica and the
soil applied silica and we should be
able to evaluate if it's at a safe level
from that point and also evaluate how
well the plants are able to take up the
silica
and we spray the silica the foliar
silica weekly
oh we spray it actually we start we're
going to continue to spray it throughout
the extent of this study so
well into flowering
yes hi
well what is the contributing factor to
the size difference in between um here
and then
all right this is a great question so
the question is what do i think the
contributing factor is between the size
difference here and in the film and
answer that question is
um so
we have okay if you just look back here
there's a little funny looking arm
situation and that black thing on top is
a par sensor and we also have a power
sensor and grow dome um so one of the
main things i think is that it's much
warmer in the grow dome in here and
obviously the plants are really enjoying
that the second thing is that
uh the par
in this area is there there's more
planted parts plant available radiation
so that's how much radiation is
available for the plant to
photosynthesize the par is higher in
here just by nature of the fact that
this is a clear plastic and the growth
is covered in
white plastic and if you look in there
there's a greater internode length and
usually when the light level is low the
plants will stretch more to
obtain more light so i think it's a
factor of the fact that it's much hotter
in there the plants are very happy with
that also there's greater internode
length because there's less plant
available radiation
any other questions savannah we have a
question yes um a question about the
triangle mainly i know that that's
labels that you as a systemic and you
can go up to 28 days between
applications on that so did you go that
length did you see better results with
triangle and those are any fighting
toxicity great question so the question
is um
trigo which is the
more conventional style fungicide it's
labeled you can spray you can wait
between 28 days to spray the next
ground of that and have we seen
phytotoxicity and what have we done so
we opted to go for a two week interval
with our trigo um and we haven't noticed
any photo toxicity yet we've only
sprayed it twice at this point
um but we will be
noting if there are any effects from
that and it has had excellent control so
far i haven't seen any powdered mildew
on any of our tribal plots at any of the
four locations where this trial is
replicated
that's a great question
i'm not sure yet but
i'm definitely sure that
there will be a link to it on the
cornell hemp website so feel free to
check that out and maybe larry will
tweet about it when it comes out though
our chris
all right any other question
yeah that's a great question so one
thing that i didn't go over that's
really important is that powdery mildew
really enjoys it when it's warm when
there's low
actual like
wetness so it doesn't like a lot of rain
but it likes it when it's very humid um
and so
it does enjoy this environment because
it's warmer than the outdoors and also
because it doesn't rain on the leaves
and because there's high humidity in
here and powdery mildew also really
likes it when there's a strong binaural
fluctuation in the
temperature so when it's cooler at night
and warmer during the day and in here it
does cool off at night time so it enjoys
that aspect of this environment
um
yeah so that's the answer to that
question any other questions
um
[Music]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu